[Music]
welcome back to off the record what we
talked about whatever man has just been
chance to puppies you guys always have
so many [ __ ] toys because my mom's
friend keeps thinking that our house
needs dog dog yeah like literally like a
halfway house for dog like because um so
so like what we used to have like three
dogs one pass and then still then what
later and another one passed it was only
one dog and then my mom's friend was
like oh hey I found this dog on the
street do you want to like foster for a
while my mom was like no I don't want to
take care of any more dogs like it's so
heartbreaking to see these like dogs
pass away and I was like I'll just take
care of him for just a little bit then
we'll like foster him elsewhere right
and then after like a week or so my mom
got attached it was like oh that's why
she is she like I would feel so bad if I
had to like get rid of him or like take
him else out like cuz you know what
happens if he goes in the shelter you
might get euthanized and I was like okay
yeah sure right and then like that's for
like a few months later that same friend
it was like hey you know my friend had a
litter of puppies I got I saved this
black puppy for you because I know you
like black dogs and my mom was like well
I know I don't want any more puppies and
then my dad saw the puppy was like Oh
water yo the go order she's so cute I
have a connection with her my dad and
then my mom was like look okay me maybe
I mean she is really cute and it's a
woman and then like literally a month
later her sister from the same litter
was actually dropped off at our house
from the same friend who was like hey
don't take care of this dog because like
the people who wanted this dog it turns
out that their son is allergic and this
dog has no home and then my mom was like
no no more dogs and my dad was like oh
well though their pup you might be like
alone if the other two pass away so like
what you know maybe it's the puppies
have a connection how many dogs do you
have
it's for now my grandpa would kick your
[ __ ] dad's ass pal so there's four
dogs but how many dogs path like two
right yeah from the time that I was with
you guys in JK yeah so I met one of them
or two of them yeah mm-hmm you brought
some to my house at least you made this
topic fun we're talking about dead dogs
I'm sorry good no but we replaced them
so it's okay traditional what kind of
dogs are the the new Daleks Russell
terrier and chihuahuas
yeah yeah yeah she always has these
little ass Chihuahua dogs like and it's
always coming I'm like which one is this
one now Oh steady for camera steady
nice I like a dog and they howl to like
oh yeah one of them actually it's so the
maker wall - right do they jump in and
swim around oh no no no no no no no they
do so one of them recently got spayed oh
the puppy I why you do that to me she
got like spayed recently Oh and so like
and so like we didn't take her out for
like a walk and so I heard her at home
and she was like all by herself because
I think she saw all three dogs like go
out the door without her and she's like
she's like an herbaceous like she like
looking out there the door like the
backyard or I want her go
I don't like what are you having for I'm
right here she's like you don't want you
you boring ass he's also got a [ __ ]
cone around her neck also she can never
have sex in her life
I know all right good lord I'd [ __ ]
yeah and she deserves to cry a little
bit yeah if I ever hear you howling like
that I'll be like oh no Steve it did you
to me I know
yeah but they're they're really cute but
they're definitely a lot of work though
I think like my dad's not home for the
most part so he's not really there to
take care of the dogs and it ends up
being on my mom and now my mom's like
presenting my dad a lot because she was
like this guy never [ __ ] cleans up
we're where the [ __ ] your daddy's not
home he's working oh he's a sessional ha
he's just so small that like it's okay
for him to go away yeah you tell him
that your business is so small that he
doesn't need me to reiterate that okay
hey your dad your business is really
small I don't think you won't care it's
so tiny
it's impossible to give Khurana so how
many people even a business do you even
have any customers dad so how are you
gonna get infected are you sure it's not
it's a business not just a dream dad but
like he knows that his business is
considered a small business our business
is small true yeah yeah small but
impactful family family small and
impactful yeah it uses the motion of the
ocean the way the business does things
is what's satisfies the woman the climax
yes projections where you live back at
home now at home I know I just wanted
the people to know yeah I've been at
home been trying to save up money so I
can buy a house do you ever put the
other guy like a year or a time that you
said like you buy 20 20 or 23 warm
you have like coming next week so are
you and your boyfriend just gonna like
move in and out of each other's houses
and stuff and like borrow each other's
spaces yeah I mean the moment that we're
able to find a house that we like then
yeah we'll move in what about you Ryan
how's your quarantine my quarantines all
over the place do ya like so I've
literally literally all over the place
so yeah I was button-head to my family a
lot so I moved out temporary
can you talk about it will you talk
about it
I won't specify all the details I just
got into it with my dad a little bit -
what's his name what's his full name
yeah so I've moved out temporarily with
my girlfriend and so I'm living with her
right now and then I'm going to have to
help her move out of state because she's
got to go to a residency a medical
residency somewhere and then after that
I come home with that my parents don't
owe me coming back home because I'll
have been traveling so that I'm gonna
need a little Brandon for a little bit
and then that I'm gonna go hopefully
move back home so the next two months
for me are just gonna be do you have to
drive a u-haul truck for her no no we're
just we're gonna ship most of the stuff
hopefully you know you're gonna fly with
her yeah yeah so we gotta bring the cat
too so that'll be a real interest but
you would if you had doing yeah yeah if
I had to you drive a Penske wouldn't you
oh I Drive I would drive a budgets look
at this guy yeah what's a budget the
yellow one yeah orange budget orange
right Pinsky's yellow yeah okay don't
forget that ladies as Ryan enters a
long-distance relationship that Ryan is
very loyal like that this is your first
time living with a partner I mean like I
stay over sometimes be I mean that's the
first time like living like together for
an extended period on bases at each
other yet no no thrown sex juices at
each other splashing in that stage of
the relationship we're not you're not
frequently you know encountering each
other I think there's a lot of [ __ ]
going yet well plus I've drilled all
those all the vases into the into the
into the furnitures to make sure
can't pick them up so yeah so I think
ahead yeah that's my that's my goal for
this court to avoid the furniture
throwing he's a hairy I just followed by
dad I can't fight with my girlfriend out
of places to stay if I follow Brandon
man gonna be a rough ride back home man
girls are gonna love that Ryan they're
gonna love hearing that you can stay
with me for quarantine yeah I'm an extra
room how long have you guys been
together
uh three years now a two and a half
three years yes Wow a lot of trust then
yeah for a long-distance relationship
Laura yeah so I mean but I'm planning on
like going out to see her to Leon it's
not like I'm it's gonna be like Oh see
you in two years kind of deal how long
she's out there for two years
you got a two-year residency so she'll
be um she'll be yeah I'd living out
there like do nursing pharmacy so I'm
super proud of her yeah she wouldn't got
the Gothel residency that she wanted so
yeah solid Asian when did checked off
all the boxes she's a pharmacist yeah I
had met JK fans who are Asian pharmacist
because they're filling my prescription
yeah twice but one time I had kidney
stones in the second time I was I was
sick with what I feel like was Ronis
like back in December like it was like
yeah the the population of Asian farm
Asian female pharmacist is apparently
like 70% or something likes crazy high
number so yeah so it's like a really
high percentage of like Asian female
pharmacists is just just a thing maybe
you didn't sell it in Southern
California but I hear it's just a thing
like in general so good for her man but
yeah she's killing it so far super proud
of her it's like a Illuminati of
pharmacy yeah there's like an Asian girl
connection that's going on how come you
didn't become a pharmacist I wanted to
pursue my dreams and go how come her
dreams is not pills I have no interest
in pushing drugs your dreams are not
practical okay my dreams were more about
like pushing out animation and cartoons
how do they help people how does that
help people you can learn a good lesson
from cartoons okay like what like learn
to love your family respect more that's
what it say together
curtains are you watch I did I just
watched Malik out he just destroy his
life time it trying to kill a roadrunner
[ __ ] guy on a cartoon that I like
growing up okay I like cartoons that
have a message no that is the message
just like don't don't have them all be
dick don't [ __ ] to consume your whole
life after chasing after one thing to
destroy yourself
like maybe animation living your dream
with JK I want to I'm sure I was you
know like JK JK helped me get my foot in
the door in production and like I'm
forever grateful for that and I was able
to get a job into animation in
production yeah it's like a disposable
rag for you you're able to use it and
then tossed it when it's not there for
like six years
I mean you're still here right now yeah
exactly good point jinkies a sticky rag
it's still on your shoe that's why
you're still here no it's a toilet paper
that's stuck to your shoe that you just
embarrassed uh but it won't leave and
you're gonna you're wearing a nice dress
and it's just staining it and it's like
tarnishing your image that's what it is
you can only hope yeah how come you not
put my number down I didn't get any
calls like for references like it's
Julie a good worker I got one you did
yeah it actually did from Julia know
from Julia's employer did you really I
actually did I did I'm not kidding right
now he puts his number - your box she
put me down - someone who works with her
yes because I wanted like a variety a
variety I think they would have called
me if I picked up the phone maybe they
did white you want to like go because
Steve's not a part of the company oh you
need a nagaraj no she wanted to show her
of references but she's worked with that
isn't a part of the company actual
co-workers bosses interesting who else
did you put down as references your dog
company so they called my house and they
just put them on the fire yeah that's a
solid endorsements yours sound like a
good boy yeah yeah no I put Steve and I
put Joe ask Joe yeah we all get it I
feel like maybe during that time you
like there was a lot going on I'm not
quite sure I don't know I don't know why
should you want to bother you
yeah I just remembered that was like oh
I think like there's a log-log Farley I
don't think I've never been a very busy
man I think that probably you're afraid
that you're on the phone with your
future employer and Bart say hey let's
second my son has such a cute butt let
me take all this we got to change each
other we had a photo shoot we both have
diapers on look like if I had both
bosses on like would that be okay
there's usually only one space for one
name I think for the boss yeah yeah for
the Pennines you say she's like go solve
it for him I just did
so how did the phonecall go down with
her employers find her I would have
sabotaged it no I mean she's okay
between me and you I don't think she's
someone that you would like to hire yep
yeah I mean when you come back I'm like
oh you did get the job I said she has
interesting feelings towards Jews did
you did you notice anything go missing
after the interview all right it's gone
you're not getting it
so has she told you yet Oh she'll say
she hasn't told you oh she will
okay well Syd yeah I think it's better
if she tells you I think by law I can't
say anything yeah I'm signed an Indian
so I don't know it's kind of weird
because we never do that right we never
call like when we interview people we
just go I like this guy you like this
guy let's [ __ ] try respect yeah if
you get it sometimes we don't even know
that someone got hired until Michael
little goes I like this guy's editing
for us yeah that's all that's all that's
all mine worked
Michael was like hey you know how to
edit all right well this how you do it I
think I just showed up at your house and
I was like I'm here to pick up footage
[Music]
because I didn't know you guys all live
together to it so this is like showed up
at this house it was just this dark you
know and all the lights are off at
everything and then Byron also came up
to the door know just like are you it's
not doing it footage here because
Michael wasn't answering his phone just
go to the door okay dragged to a frat
house yeah for reals
it was quiet - it was because if it was
loud I would have been like all this
sounds like a house where people you
know people are doing things but it was
like dead quiet at like 11:00 at night
or something you can see in the corner
no no everyone was in the back you know
that back like yeah yeah yeah yeah Sam
it's just like this could be the wrong
house I'm just interrupting this like
dark house yeah I don't know why my
house was so dark no front light and you
know what they did because it was so
damn dark they got a light bulb and then
they rigged it was the most get
[ __ ] ever dude like we got like an
extension cord and we ran it and so you
just saw a light bulb outside with a
switch thing where you could go like
push in whatever and that was our front
door light I don't know come on guys
didn't kick it in the front because the
front of the house without living room
is it's really well lit it's a big
window how come everyone's kinda yeah
dark there's no there's no light plus
it's like the living room area like all
of their computers and stuff and
everything that they're like working on
is all in the back thanks to the kitchen
- yeah so all of them used to just
distribute footage and all that in a den
area and that's where they did the work
so the the living room was always dark
and it was always empty
I'm more curious as to what everyone's
first impression Joey it was pretty
normal to be honest like I do like it
didn't get weird until like a couple
meetings in I think you guys all broaden
your guns to like show them off or
whatever I was like oh this is getting
weird
yeah he's right no cuz I came here for
the first time I had no idea what this
place was I had met you guys at the
roast for Timmy but then I didn't even I
had never seen the channel before so
then I just show up here I don't even
know who's in charge of water or
anything like I you should have done
your research before you got on CJ
connects what is it
Tim's roses before JP met they met at Jo
Tim's Rose yes Nikki was always with us
yeah but we we usually we mainly had
Nikki for ask the fields so it never
even occurred like and then she started
coming to JK news and then it was like
oh [ __ ] wait your husband's in you -
yeah like boyfriend up department-issued
but my husband does call me a lot school
we invited him after Nikki Nikki was
like oh yeah my husband Steve does this
like you should no no we saw his comedy
and we're like hole crap wait I thought
he was like a prank guy right right and
then that's where it was like wait he
does comedy and like improv and all this
stuff oh we should just bring him in
so then I came here cold actually during
the first video on the end I even get
Bart's name wrong because I don't know
Bart's name what'd you say
I don't remember but I remember Gio's
like this is Bart and I was like oh
right I know but I didn't like I just
didn't know yet cuz I'm bad at names
first of all which is why Nicky had told
me of you guys before but I didn't
[ __ ] remember the names because they
do you meet so many people in this
[ __ ] space obviously you guys know I
had heard of Joel Mallya Joel Mallya I
had heard of before because I think
Nicky read it to me a bunch and I just
thought it was like a nut sounding like
a call no I thought it was his full name
he was Joe last name Molly mr mallya
right I didn't know he's he's in my
phone to this day as Joel Molly cuz I
thought that was his message hi that's
two separate names Joseph and then
mallya it's just Joe Mallya like Joe
first name last name Molly yeah so I
just didn't know I didn't know the
hierarchy or anything I like who is in
charge with water who's yeah most people
think that a lot of people actually
think that TIF owns the company because
she's the host Nikki thought Julia yeah
so usually we all were all tubers right
usually you're the person sending the
emails doing this [ __ ] and so they all
thought because the the person was Julia
that she was the owner of the channel
nobody [ __ ] knows yeah that was funny
like when I heard that I was like oh god
I was like I don't never think I would
ever own this channel like I don't even
think I would have even had the ability
that you would want to own the job yeah
whoa should have milked it though are we
yeah weird you guys are [ __ ] we're my
first time meeting you guys like well I
actually that part was pretty normal
when I met him until you really get to
know [ __ ] like I should know him that's
rare and stranger the more you get to
know him and then you're like the
opposite like when I first met you you
were even thick at Bart's house yet we
were waiting for you or something and
then we all here it's just like you just
hear you know louder louder louder as
you get closer and you walk their doors
they're just like [ __ ] nuts your ball
don't lie oh yeah yeah that was our
first impression of you but then the
more I get to know you the more normal
you become in my mind
yeah I don't remember you how much of an
impact you made on his life uh with lats
doing I wish she would Nate flew in the
penthouse in the front you hand the fine
I remember us three
oh I remember was that night and we were
filming like that Halloween special or
something else and then it was at in
front of your front porch or whatever is
when we met KC or jr. or we met them all
at the same time right with a Wacka yep
okay and then I was like why are we
meeting these people I don't know what
friends are good no you're like I don't
know who like why you got invited or
whatever but there's Jill I think Jill
this is always networking and pulling
people together and it's all I just come
on snow or filming anyways yeah that's
all it's kind of like whose friend is
this okay and then um I didn't know that
uh Walking Dead Glen came to and I was
fanboy like a [ __ ] cuz we took
the same flight to Japan and he was in
front of me and I think he had a baby so
he was sleepy he was tired so I was like
but then come to find out that he told
Bart that he came to that house - oh
yeah back home that we just had all
kinds of people come come to the house
and cuz we were it was kind of like
social network where it's like a living
room but there's computers and then
shelves for merch and just all kinds of
stuff and then I went to this one dinner
and then the guy from walking dead was
there and I'm all she's not the guy from
walking yeah that's the kind of Walking
Dead that's all cool and then after
he'll say what's that part I'm like who
are you I'm like what yes man everyone
was just like going through that and he
was like I almost felt like it was like
a rite of passage like if I was Asian
American and I didn't stop by the JK
house I wasn't really in the whole
community and I'm like oh [ __ ] I didn't
even know we were like that I always
thought people were like I guess we have
to invite
like every time does it not bad that's
that's that's how it is now yeah are you
sure man I feel like that was a dream
like that whole time I feel like it was
such a dream because I don't remember a
lot of stuff that went down and I was
like where was I existing like mentally
like where was I at I don't know I think
you just I you just had that like
passion in your eyes of like wanting to
just make something cuz I just remember
the first time I saw you to die no let
me tell you that well the first time I
met you you were you were in your
Haitian Mom outfit you got the first
time I met you you were in your asian
mom outfit remember like I walk though
stupid I hate Joe I'm your new intern I
just remember you're like oh hey yeah
hey nice to meet you know why cuz
somebody didn't tell me you were my new
intern I had to process this [ __ ] at
this moment and I go should I say the
truth or should I back up the person
that told you that you are my intern and
I'm gonna have to have a conversation
with this person and now look at what
happen and then when I first met Bart it
was on a JK film set I think it was when
there was a ghost in the house so that
was like your skit you just moved in a
ghost
that's the name is good I don't remember
where was it the girl yeah Julia from
the vine girl I thought the first time I
met you was here here right there yeah
no honestly because I I remember how
jarring it was for someone to say hey
I'm your new intern and I'm like what
both didn't know she's a new intern but
they rolled with you briefly at Joe's
old place that's sure I was even a part
of that shoe no you weren't a part of it
but you dropped by to see geo pathology
I was a part of that sure she she was
producing nationally and I was just
there helping but like she dropped you
dropped by really quick but you didn't
stay for very long that's very sweet of
me but yeah it was really sweet of you
and then like so like I
remember like I don't think I made much
of an impression because I didn't say
anything to you cuz you checked up on
geo and then like you looked at me and
you're like I don't know you and then
you just walked hey he's very personable
yeah
[Music]